bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver à
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne un débat sur l'évasion
fiscale ce débat fait suite à la
commission d' enquête sur l'évasion des
actifs hors de france réalisée en juin
dernier à la demande du groupe
communiste déjà interrogé sur ce thème
en séance par le sénateur communiste du
nord éric bocquet jérôme cahuzac le
ministre du budget avait promis des
moyens supplémentaires de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale il s'agissait
notamment de renforcer les pouvoirs
d'investigation ou encore de
recouvrement de l'administration mais le
gouvernement va-t-il aller plus loin et
bien éléments de réponse avec ce débat
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur
l'évasion des capitaux et des actifs
hors de france et ses incidences
fiscales demande de la commission
enquêtes sur l'évasion des capitaux et
les actifs hors de france et ses
incidences fiscales
la parole est à notre collègue philippe
dominati président de la commission d'
enquête sur l'évasion des capitaux et
des actifs hors de france et ses
incidences fiscales
chers collègues vous avez la parole
madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je voudrais remercier la conférence des
présidents d'avoir inscrit ce débat à
notre ordre du jour avec une mention
particulière pour le président du sénat
qui a je le crois a usé de toute son
autorité pour donner aux travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur l'évasion des
capitaux des actifs hors de france et
ses incidences fiscales
ce prolongement en séance publique
j'ai eu le plaisir et l'honneur de
présider cette commission et je crois
que le rapport qu'elle a adopté sur
proposition de son rapporteur notre
collègue éric bocquet mérite ce premier
prolongement
je voudrais vous rappeler que ce rapport
a été adopté à l'unanimité vote qui sans
être tout à fait exceptionnel dans notre
haute assemblée témoigne d'une profonde
satisfaction sur la méthode suivie par
le rapporteur
mais aussi d'un accord sur un assez
grand nombre des conclusions et des
considérants du rapport et au delà d'une
volonté partagée de lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale internationale telle
qu'elle est envisagée dans ce rapport il
n'est pas simple de réunir dans le temps
imparti par notre constitution
l'ensemble des conditions permettant de
traiter sérieusement les conditions
posées par la proposition de résolution
du groupe crc qui dans le cadre du droit
de tirage des groupes institué par la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 à
fonder notre commission d' enquête à ce
propos je voudrais dire que si nous
devons à l'évidence respecter les délais
constitutionnels nous gagnerions sans
doute beaucoup à ce qu'une fois la prise
d'acte effectué par la conférence des
présidents
les délais puisse courir utilement c'est
à dire que nous puissions éviter de
gaspiller plusieurs semaines très
précieuse dans le cadre contraint qui
nous est imposée sans que nos commission
denquête puisse travailler effectivement
deux solutions sont envisageables soit
la nomination concomitante avec la
décision de la conférence des présidents
des membres de la commission soit une
jurisprudence permettant de conditionner
la course du délai 2
moi à la nomination de leurs membres
dans notre cas nous avons dû attendre
autour de trois semaines pour la
désignation des membres pour que la
désignation des membres interviennent ce
qui représente les inconvénients que
chacun comprend tout seul
ces questions de délai se retrouve
d'ailleurs au terme des travaux des
commissions d'enquêté chaque membre de
la commission a disposé d'une semaine en
fin de parcours pour consulter le projet
de rapport
ce qui est dans les règles mais
constituait un vrai un temps vraiment
trop court pour s'approprier pleinement
un document si important une semaine il
est bien possible qu'une partie de ses
difficultés doivent être attribués à la
complexité du sujet proposé aux travaux
de la commission denquête complexité
technique des problèmes que posent
l'évasion fiscale internationale qui
engagent des techniques aussi variés que
le droit comptable le droit financier le
droit des sociétés tout confluent des
questions fiscales au coeur du sujet
complexité des analyses financières et
économiques en jeu sur laquelle la
littérature disponible est souvent bien
évasive mais aussi complexité du fait de
l'ampleur des questions posées par la
proposition de résolution
fondatrice qui il faut bien le
reconnaître n'avait peut-être pas toutes
les caractéristiques que l'on peut
attendre défi soumis aux investigations
d'une commission denquête en particulier
sous l'angle de leur détermination
autrement dit le champ ouvert aux
travaux de la commission était si vaste
que chacun comprendra que quelques choix
ont dû être faits pour répondre aussi
bien que possible à la mission qui lui
avait été confié peut-être serait-il
raisonnable à l'avenir de circonscrire
davantage les questions posées ou alors
de recourir à des structures disposant
de davantage de temps il est vrai que
nos missions d'information n'ont pas les
mêmes prérogatives que celle des
commission denquête sur ce point je dois
témoigner que la seule haine étiqueter
des procédures représente un atout mais
que pour autant les sanctions dont
dispose la commission denquête ne sont
pas également adapté à leurs pratiques
par ailleurs il serait justifié de
réfléchir à l'attribution des
dispositions les plus utiles aux
commission denquête que sont le
témoignage sous serment
et les droits d'accès aux informations
nécessaires à d'autres instances
le renforcement du rôle du parlement y
gagnerait sans doute
pardonnez moi ces propos institutionnels
un peu généraux mais l'amélioration de
notre gouvernance publique est un grand
chantier de longue haleine et si nous
avons fait un très grand pas en 2008 à
l'initiative du président sarkozy
rien ne nous empêche d'améliorer ce qui
peut encore l'être
permettez moi aussi de vous indiquer que
les travaux d'une commission denquête
doivent être situés dans son
environnement ce qui est un défi
permanent pour son président il ne doit
jamais oublier que la commission
denquête s'arrête là où la justice
pénale intervient dans le temps de notre
mission d instruction judiciaire ont pu
être ouvertes sur tel ou tel dossier que
nous avons été conduit à envisager
nous nous sommes adaptés aux rythmes de
la vie judiciaire mais il faut bien
reconnaître que lassant sellerie ne nous
a pas systématiquement informés des
initiatives des magistrats par ailleurs
les commission denquête interviennent
dans des champs où existent des organes
de supervision éventuellement de thé de
pouvoir de sanction il est naturel que
ceux ci soient informés quand une
commission denquête vient à se voir
signalé des infractions avant même que
le rapport ne soit rendu ou dans le
cadre de la publication du rapport la
durée de vie limitée des commission
denquête pose un problème de suite que
nous avons pu rencontrer dans quelques
cas et qu'il nous faudra résoudre pour
achever ce retour d'expérience je
voudrais encore ajouter deux
observations premier lieu il me semble
que les informations demandées aux
entreprises ont généralement été
fournies par celle ci dans des
conditions acceptables
tandis que pour les administrations
solliciter les retours ont été
sensiblement plus incertain je dois même
indiqué que certaines informations ne
sont jamais parvenus malgré le
changement de gouvernement un temps nous
avons eu la chance de compter parmi les
membres de la commission denquête madame
briques qui réclamait à juste titre que
le rapport sur le contrôle fiscal des
filiales françaises détenus à l'étranger
qui ne lui avait pas été transmis en
tant que rapporteur général soit
transmis à la commission denquête il ne
l'a jamais été
le président de la commission denquête
cesse aussi de tout coeur monsieur le
ministre à l'expression du
mécontentement de notre ancien
rapporteur général
en second lieu je voudrais relayer une
préoccupation unanime des membres de la
commission denquête en formulant le
souhait que nous puissions accorder aux
sujets dont nous nous sommes saisis
natation soutenu dans le temps notre
commission a beaucoup travaillé j'y
reviendrai mais il était hors de portée
d'apprécier la totalité des éléments de
la cause si je puis dire
or comme nous sommes vraiment au coeur
d'une affaire de principe
la force de la loi fiscale et du
consentement à l'impôt mais aussi d'une
question fondamentale pour notre devenir
économique et financier la commission
denquête a exprimé la volonté que sous
une forme à définir le sénat puisse
continuer d'exercer ses missions de
contrôle et d'évaluation sur un sujet si
essentiel j'ajoute partager le sentiment
des dirigeants des très grandes
entreprises françaises que nous avons
auditionnés selon lequel un dialogue
régulier avec la représentation
nationale sur leurs activités sur leurs
comptes constituerait un véritable
progrès de méthode
notre commission a beaucoup travaillé h
10 et j'y reviens brièvement nous avons
procédé à 90 audition au sénat
deux responsables de l'action publique
des professions du chiffre du droit des
chefs d'entreprise d'anciens sportifs
professionnels à quoi se sont ajoutés
une quarantaine d'entretiens lors des
déplacements de la commission ceux ci
ont été au nombre de trois plus un
déplacement du rapporteur à londres je
m'empresse de vous indiquer que nous
n'avons pas fréquenter les plages de
sable fin qu'on associe généralement aux
paradis fiscaux et que les délégations
de la commission a été à chaque fois
très restreinte
les trois membres qu'elles ont mobilisé
ont effectué des missions à bruxelles à
jersey et en suisse ce qui n'est assez
loin de représenter l'image reçue des
paradis fiscaux nib les bahamas ni les
élevés assuré n'être technique ni les
îles cayman convenait que nous avons été
pour le moins respectueux des
contraintes budgétaires
en somme nous n'avons pas accédé à notre
cote de notre côté au délit présumé de
l'évasion
cette rigueur se retrouvent je le crois
dans le rapport adopté par la commission
denquête face à l'ampleur des sujets
proposés à notre étude note rapporteur a
eu le mérite de recenser les principaux
éléments d'appréciation d'en faire
l'analyse la plus rigoureuse possible et
de nous proposer dutil pistes de réforme
au vrai la commission a consacré deux
remarquables efforts à circonscrire son
sujet puisqu'aussi bien l'évasion
fiscale internationale est un pavillon
sous lequel navigue de nombreuses
marchandises les d'ailleurs assez
remarquable qu'un objet est finalement
assez fréquemment rencontrés dans la
presse soit si peu ou si mal déterminées
en particulier dans la littérature
savante
nous sommes le pays de la fiscalité pas
celui de l'analyse de la fiscalité d'où
vient peut-être une forme d'exigences
d'existentialisme fiscale qui a conduit
à un système particulièrement peu
satisfaisant notre rapporteur a eu
également la sagesse de proposer à la
commission de recentrer son propos sur
l'évasion fiscale internationale plutôt
que d'embraser l'évasion des capitaux et
ses incidences fiscales par une forme d'
inversion des termes de la saisine
sagesse partagé par l'ensemble de la
commission mais aussi habileté
car au fond si nous pouvons avoir
quelques divergences sur la définition
de l'évasion fiscale nous sommes
naturellement réunis par une même
volonté qui est de prévenir et de
sanctionner les pratiques qui
aboutissent à tricher avec notre droit
sans doute aurions-nous eu plus de
difficultés à nous accorder si nous
avions envisagé les effets de notre
législation fiscale sur notre tissu
économique
le rapporteur a légitimement considérer
que cette question n'était pas au centre
des investigations de la commission
je me situe quelques instants aux
limites de mon rôle de président de la
commission denquête telle qu'elle s'est
déroulé pour évoquer ce sujet d'une
conception large de l'évasion fiscale
qui aurait pu nous conduire à aborder si
je crois très naturel de s'inquiéter des
pertes de recettes fiscales résultant de
tricherie j'incline à penser que nous
devrions consacrer autant d'énergie
à mesurer les pertes de substance
financière et de dynamisme économique
que nous occasionne une fiscalité que le
rapport décrit très honnêtement comme
l'une des plus lourdes d'europe et par
conséquent du monde encore n'avions-nous
rien vu si j'en juge par le choc fiscal
que votre majorité s'apprête à infliger
aux français vous l'enrobé au nom d'une
soi-disant sélectivité de l'effort mais
nous savons bien que le long de deux
chocs se proposera bien vite ou sous
traitants petits producteurs aux ménages
les plus fragiles
notre rapporteur a souligné à juste
titre l'environnement de concurrence
fiscale existant dans le monde
on peut certes le regretter même si trop
souvent la dénonciation de la
concurrence fiscale dissimulent des
carences de compétitivité du système
public
il n'empêche que le réalisme veut qu'on
reconnaisse que nos choix collectifs ont
été d'ouvrir nos économies et quincy
nous sommes confrontés à la nécessité de
nous donner des règles fiscales qu'on
soutenable sans doute pouvoir nous nous
accorder pour agir contre les excès de
la concurrence fiscale
ce que l'europe et le cdo ont commencé
d'entreprendre avec le processus de
démantèlement des régimes fiscaux
contribuant à une concurrence fiscale
dommageable mais de grâce ne mettons pas
la charrue avant les boeufs et
n'imaginons pas que nos partenaires se
rallieront comme un seul homme à notre
fiscalité
dans le contexte de concurrence fiscale
que nous connaissons les orientations
que vous suivez constitueront un
handicap de compétitivité coût
supplémentaire pour un pays qui doit
restaurer sa compétitivité
l'objet de notre commission denquête
n'était pas d'évaluer cette forme
d'évasion fiscale par le découragement
des talents qui se produit toujours
quand l'impôt se fait confiscatoire nous
l'avons cependant croiser à plusieurs
reprises et notamment quand lors
d'auditions d'un fervent soutien du
président à vie publique et de sa
proposition n'était d'instaurer une
tranche d'impôt à 75% le même concéda au
grand jamais il ne conseillerai à son
fils de choisir la france pour résidence
du fait du niveau comparatif de ses
enfants
cet épisode montre que s'il est facile
de porter des jupes
n'importe ps sur une justice qui
passerait par la mise au ban des
soi-disant riche il est beaucoup plus
responsable et désirable pour un pays de
disposer de gouvernement réalistes et de
façonner sa fiscalité pour assurer sa
prospérité
or celle ci ne passe pas par la
restauration structurel des finances
publiques qui souffrent a non seulement
de l'impulsion fiscale négative que vous
ferez subir au pays mais encore de façon
beaucoup plus profond de l'inévitable
affaiblissement de la base productive
que l'on doit attendre une politique
pénalisant l'investissement et le risque
nous nous retrouvons bien sûr sur ces
questions lors de l'examen du projet de
finances il en revient au strict cadre
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui pour mettre
l'accent sur quelques unes des
principales conclusions de la commission
denquête j'ai évoqué à l'instant sur le
plan politique les inquiétudes très
visible que inspire des projets fiscaux
lors de nos travaux nous avons rencontré
sur le plan plus technique le lancinant
problème de l'évaluation des
dispositions fiscales
un très grand nombre de dispositifs
fiscaux sont en cause quand on analyse
les problèmes d'évasion fiscale
internationale
et à chaque fois un même constat
s'impose le défaut trop fréquents
d'évaluation sérieuse de nos dispositifs
fiscaux
j'ai notamment à l'esprit la suppression
du régime du bénéfice mondial consolidé
qui s'est traduite par un recul de
l'information sur les opérations
réalisées par les groupes multinationaux
français pouvant habitue pouvoir aboutir
à un résultat inverse de celui recherché
je forme des voeux pour que nous
puissions porter remède cette situation
nous devons légiférer avec soin sur ceux
qui sont avec soin ce qui passe par une
réforme en profondeur du processus
d'adoption de la loi fiscale ou
l'évaluation doit occuper toute sa place
sans doute devrions nous doter notre
haute assemblée de tous les moyens
nécessaires à coup sûr nous devions nous
laisser suffisamment de temps pour
procéder à des simulations sans lesquels
la législation fiscale rélève trop
souvent de la technique du doigt mouillé
en météorologie
l'une des propositions du rapport est
que nous complétions notre arsenal
législatif parler diction d'une
disposition générale condamnant
d'évasion fiscale internationale
cette proposition me donne l'occasion de
souligner l'ampleur des mesures adoptées
lors de la précédente législature pour
prévenir et combattre l'évasion fiscale
internationale
le rapport en bresse la liste avec une
grande honnêteté
même si le rapporteur comme c'est son
droit s'interroge sur leurs effets en
réalité 23 mesures ont été adoptées sous
la précédente législature législature
dont un assez grand nombre ont été votés
ici à l'unanimité on peut bien sûr faire
mieux et nous pouvons nous accorder avec
nombre des propositions contenues dans
le rapport de notre commission denquête
je crois qu'il s'agit d'une suggestion
légitime mais je dois cependant insisté
sur la nécessité d'assurer une certaine
sécurité juridique aux contribuables de
sorte que si nous engagions dans cette
voie nous devrions particulièrement
veillé à cette exigence
je veux rappeler également le principe
constamment réaffirmées par nos
juridictions selon lequel nul n'est
contraint d'employer la voile plus
imposé et que si l'optimisation fiscale
ne doit pas déborder sur des pratiques
abusives
on ne serait là reprocher à des
contribuables à qui on donne
l'opportunité quand n'hésite pas et y
recourir
la précédente ministre du budget que
nous avons auditionné avait jugé qu'en
matière de lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale la seule stratégie
efficace et elle a peur du gendarme
il est assez peu contestable qu'en effet
nous avons recouru assez largement à
cette stratégie dans le passé en
renforçant considérablement les moyens
d' enquête de l'administration fiscale
le rapport de notre commission denquête
préconise une voix complémentaires
consistant à améliorer la gouvernance
fiscale des entreprises et à instaurer
une forme de contrôle en continu entre
les contribuables à fort enjeu et
l'administration fiscale ces deux
orientations présentent chacun un
véritable intérêt je souligne que ces
différentes pistes devraient être
accompagnées des conditions nécessaires
à la sécurisation des choix fiscaux elle
passera nécessairement par des
obligations de confidentialité mais
aussi par une prise de responsabilité de
l'administration fiscale qui devra
éclairer plus systématiquement les
contribuables mais aussi le parlement
sur ses positions sur l'application de
la loi fiscale
j'ai tout à l'heure évoqué la
concurrence fiscale le rapport met bien
en évidence les problèmes de
coordination qui se posent dans la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale internationale
tant au niveau international qu'en
europe
le président sarkozy a beaucoup fait
pour mettre la communauté internationale
face à ses responsabilités au regard des
paradis fiscaux
si une tâche qui n'est pas achevée
convenant ans
c'est à juste titre que le rapporteur a
insisté sur la fixation d'objectifs
ambitieux à notre diplomatie parmi
lesquels celui de mener à bien et
d'amplifier le processus de l'examen par
les pairs mais aussi de conclure au
mieux les négociations des différentes
directives européennes en cours et de
faire pression sur les pays qui rechigne
à pratiquer l'échangé d'informations qui
est le pivot de la lutte contre une
partie importante de l'évasion fiscale
internationale
nous avons dans le passé adopter une
position dure face aux tentations visant
à déroger aux principes d'action de la
communauté internationale sur ce point
en particulier nous avons toujours
marqué notre position propositions
émanant de certains pays dont notre
voisin suisse de soldes est certaine
situation fiscale au prix de quelques
entorse à ses principes
certains de nos voisins l'allemagne le
royaume-uni l'autriche n'ont pas montré
la même fidélité à ses principes
je voudrais monsieur le ministre que
vous puissiez nous préciser si vous
entendez vous situer dans la continuité
de l'action de la précédente majorité
sur ce point une série de propositions
visent à renforcer l'efficacité
l'efficacité de la coordination de la
politique de la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale internationale en la situant
dans un ensemble plus vaste de
protection des intérêts financiers
publics la création d'un haut
commissariat irait dans ce sens mais
c'est également
le cas des propositions concernant la
prescription fiscale le régime des
présomptions dans le champ des prix de
transfert
les recommandations portant sur les
moyens du contrôle fiscal et de nombreux
autres ces propositions méritent à
l'évidence un débat approfondi que
j'appelle de mes voeux
il faudra respecter les libertés
fondamentales
ce dont je crois tout le monde est
d'accord pour tenir compte des progrès
déficience que peut réaliser
l'administration fiscale donc par
exemple déploiement des moyens sur le
territoire n'est pas toujours en
harmonie avec les enjeux fiscaux et
digérer les très nombreuses mesures
adoptées lors de la précédente
législature
monsieur le président madame la
présidente
en vous renouvelant mes remerciements
pour l'organisation de ce débat je crois
pouvoir vous dire que les soixante et
une proposition de la commission
retiendront encore longtemps notre
attention sur un sujet qui le méritent
monsieur le ministre je forme des voeux
pour que le dialogue entre le sénat et
le gouvernement se poursuivent
activement sur ce point et que les
divergences qui peuvent nous séparer ne
nuisent pas notre accord que je crois
profond de voir la loi fiscale
pleinement respectée je voudrais pour
conclure remercier au nom de tous les
membres de cette commission l'ensemble
des fonctionnaires du sénat qui sous
l'impulsion de monsieur linh nous ont
permis de mener à bien cette mission
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président de la commission la parole est
à éric bocquet rapporteur de la
commission d' enquête
bien même la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues au cours
des quelques mois que la constitution a
concédé à la commission denquête créé
par le sénat à l'initiative du groupe
auquel j'ai l'honneur d'appartenir pour
explorer l'évasion fiscale
internationale nous avons voulu avant
tout comprendre et exposé de quoi
celle-ci est le nom évoqué régulièrement
au gré le plus souvent de révélations
scandaleuses l'évasion fiscale
internationale n'était tel qu'une
chimère un phénomène accidentelle ou
bien un élément courant de la vie
économique et financière contemporaine
cette question va les cons la pause
d'autant que les travaux disponible sur
ce sujet en france se singulariser par
leur extrême rareté
sinon par leur total inexistence lacunes
particulièrement choquant
s'agissant du vide des sources publiques
et faisant contraste avec une relative
abondance dans les pays étrangers anglo
saxons notamment et avec l'activisme des
officines qui promeuvent et vendant trim
est effectivement avec un grand profit
pour elle des schémas d'évasion fiscale
internationale nous pour aujourd'hui
espérer que notre commission denquête
aura été une étape dans la trajectoire
conduisant à l'indispensable
construction d'une politique publique
cohérente et résolu de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
axée sur l'efficacité et la transparence
car pour mettre fin à un suspense
intolérable je dois vous dire que la
commission denquête à identifier
l'existence de risques systémiques
d'évasion fiscale qui représentent des
enjeux financiers considérables
de sorte que l'évasion fiscale doit être
considéré comme la manifestation d'une
crise de l'impôt particulièrement graves
par ses incidences financières mais
aussi économique social et politique
franchement délétère on est quantifiant
que ce qui nous a été donnée de
quantifier
c'est à dire en devant négliger
certaines sources vraisemblablement très
considérable d'évasion fiscale comme les
échanges internationaux de service des
opérations financières internes au
groupe de sociétés ou encore les
incidences des transferts de résidence
des particuliers nous pouvons avancer un
risque excédent 30 milliards d'euros qui
est donc le bas d'une fourchette
d'estimation dont la hauteur qui devrait
être déterminée par des travaux
complémentaires pourraient se situer
bien au delà en bref la dimension du
risque financier lié à l'évasion fiscale
internationale nous est apparu comme
supérieurs aux risques
total associé à l'ensemble des risques
de fraude aux prélèvements obligatoires
estimé par le conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires
notre estimation des risques peut
sembler très élevées elles convergent
remarquablement avec celle que propose
essentiellement à l'étranger pour des
pays comparables au nôtre
les observateurs les plus attentifs du
phénomène or ces risques sont très loin
de l'être que théorique
il existe un véritable faisceau
d'indicés permettant de conclure à leur
réalisation effective
ainsi nous avons pu identifier
l'existence d'une véritable industrie
mobilisables par les candidats à
l'évasion fiscale internationale d'un
contexte globalement très favorable à la
réalisation de ces risques systémiques
qui passe par l'emploi de vecteurs les
oeuvres d'art les échanges commerciaux
des circuits de financement et le
technique juridique comptable financière
très très diversifié nous avons
également relevé l'accumulation
d'informations tendant à accréditer le
soupçon d'un phénomène massif et usuels
qu'il s'agisse par exemple de la
multiplication des découvertes portant
sur des actifs non déclarés détenus dans
tel ou tel paradis fiscal de
l'inventaire fournit des schémas évasif
réunis par l' ocde qui compte désormais
plus de 350 recettes d'évasion fiscale
ou de la réinterprétation de certains
flux financiers de soi disant
investissements directs internationaux
correspondant en fait à des prêts intra
groupe à la finalité fiscale évidente à
ce propos je souhaiterais et recevoir
des assurances sur les effets de
l'exclusion de la fiscalisation des
intérêts prévus dans le projet de loi de
finances que nous allons examiner
prochainement des opérations internes au
groupe de sociétés qui sont pourtant
particulièrement suspecte
je voudrais en être certain je dois
enfin précisé que pendant pardon je
voudrais je comprends qu'elle ne portera
que sur les groupe fiscalement intégré
mais je voudrais en être certain je dois
enfin précisé que pendant les travaux de
la commission denquête et peut-être ne
fusent pas sans lien avec eux un certain
nombre de faits sont intervenus je pense
à l'affairé ubs mais aussi à d'autres
dossiers sans doute moins grand public
qui faisant monter la partie émergée de
l'évasion fiscale internationale nous
confortent dans la conviction que
beaucoup reste encore à faire émerger
évidemment une observation essentiel
s'impose
l'évasion fiscale internationale se
nourrit de l'opacité
et celle ci est largement offerte par
l'extrême sophistication de la vie
économique contemporaine par le
renforcement de la part des processus du
matériel dans la création de valeur
économique tendance qui devant se
renforcer à l'avenir annonce une riche
prospective de la problématique de
l'évasion fiscale internationale par un
renforcement de la dimension financière
de l'économie et par une série de
défaillances internes informationnel
délibérément ménagé par certains outils
juridiques et par certains états ces
constats doivent guider la définition et
la conduite de l'action contre l'évasion
fiscale internationale
il est inutile en cette période de
stress financier d' insister beaucoup
sur l'apport que pourrait représenter
une politique permettant de recouvrer
les dettes fiscales et l'idée grâce aux
pratiques d'évasion fiscale
internationale
il faut aussi comprendre que ce que
celle ci mette en cause n'est pas
seulement le rendement nos prélèvements
mais plus encore peut-être la justice
fiscale et économique et l'autorité même
de notre démocratie
l'évasion fiscale internationale porte
une grave atteinte à l'équité de notre
système fiscal tant horizontale entre
les détenteurs de revenus analogue que
verticale entre les plus aisés et ceux
qui le sont moins
elle rompt l'égalité les conditions de
concurrence et fait obstacle aux
financements dont nous avons besoin pour
élever notre croissance potentielle
elles remettent en cause la possibilité
même de conseils démocratie solidaire et
de progrès économique et mines
l'autorité d'un lot de la loi fiscale
que nous votons elle permet de
substituer au consentement démocratique
à l'impôt qui s'exprime dans cet
hémicycle l'invite 10 l'individualisme
fiscale en créant et en prospérant
dessus des zones de non-droit voie
privilégiée de l'évasion fiscale je
voudrais insister sur ce point car je
crois que l'évasion fiscale
internationale le symptôme d'une crise
du droit fiscal confrontés aux
évolutions d'un contexte économique
marqué par une globalisation financière
dérégulé qui ébranle l'action publique
à commencer par ces concepts notre
commission denquête a dû constater que
la notion même d'évasion fiscale
internationale suscitée d'une forme
d'embarras de la pensée chez la plupart
de ses interlocuteurs en particulier les
frontières entre l'évasion fiscale et
l'optimisation fiscale sont apparus
incertaine et on se souvient du mot du
chancelier de l'échiquier britannique
is free il est identifié par référence
aux murs de la prison
notre législation fiscale porte la trace
de cet embarras et elle se trouve par
conséquent affaibli de ce fait notre
commission denquête a souhaité qu'elles
franchissent un pas décisif de son
histoire
nous pensons qu'il conviendrait ainsi
que le royaume uni a commencé de
l'entreprendre de s'attacher introduit à
notre droit une disposition générale
condamnant l'évasion fiscale
internationale
autrement dit une norme anti évasion qui
en tant que disposition globale manque
singulièrement à notre arsenal
législatif comme celle ci tend toujours
à créer un écart entre la valeur
économique intrinsèque d'une situation
et l'assiette fiscale
il conviendrait que cette norme dépasse
les concepts essentiellement juridique
qu'il y met trop souvent l'efficacité
des instruments partiel dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui pour lutter contre
les abus de droit ou les actes anormaux
de gestion après tout c'est bien ce
primat de l'économie qui anime la
réflexion sur le projet axis assiette
commune d'imposition des sociétés en
europe la nécessité de faire mieux
coïncider l'imposition et le revenu et
d'ainsi restaurer la force de l'adage ou
bi et mollo men tome i dyonis s'impose
dans un monde où la liberté des
mouvements de capitaux des biens et des
personnes
offre sur un fond de concurrence fiscale
sans garde fou à tout à chacun des
opportunités injustifiable de shopping
fiscale on l'a compris
ce n'est pas par simple intérêt
intellectuel que nous devons clarifier
notre conception de l'évasion fiscale
internationale
cette démarche doit avoir tous les
prolongements juridiques et pratiques
qu'appelle la lutte contre une pratique
aussi pernicieuses et cela commence par
l'édiction d'une énorme assez puissante
pour réduire les interstices par
lesquels elle se propage dans les
pratiques d'évasion fiscale
internationale se retrouve toujours les
effets de la déréglementation qui est un
trait fondamental de l'économie
contemporaine depuis une trentaine
d'années ainsi que l'existence d'un
contexte d'hétérogénéité des régimes
fiscaux nationaux sous ce dernier angle
la problématique des paradis fiscaux se
présente comme une forme paroxystique et
caricatural la commission denquête a
pris acte des initiatives prises par le
concert des nations à leur encontre
pour autant les paradis fiscaux ont-ils
disparu
des listes internationales ou nationales
où ils furent un temps inscrit dans
l'intention de les stigmatiser
assurément du paysage financier
international pas le moins du monde les
listes officielles se vident les listes
de comptes non déclarés se multiplient
au demeurant cette politique de la liste
des limites flagrante lice les
différentes organisations
internationales ne se recoupent pas
alors même qu'elles prétendent couvrir
des problèmes analogues de conformité
leur portée juridique nuls et leur
déclinaison au niveau national s'en
ressent à ce niveau chaque pays est en
quelque sorte face au reste du monde en
état de quasi complète incertitude sur
les décisions que prendront ces
partenaires qui sont en fait ses
concurrents autrement dit comme c'est
systématiquement le tas la
mondialisation n'est pas gouvernée sur
le plan fiscal et même l'objectif
minimal d'éliminer les nuisances les
plus caricaturales n'est pas atteint on
y retrouve la même logique de soumission
des politiques de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale à une concurrence fiscale qui
permet à l'évasion fiscale
internationale de prospérer nous avons
pu constater les effets de cette carence
en france ou non content d'avoir orienté
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
internationale des pays à fiscalité
privilégiée vers le champ plus restreint
des paradis fiscaux
nous nous sommes attachés à réduire
leurs périmètres sur la base de
considérations incompréhensible c'est
ainsi que pendant les travaux de notre
commission
par simple arrêté la liste des paradis
fiscaux a été vidé de 11 états dont le
panama paralysant un peu plus les
dispositions législatives adoptées dans
cet hémicycle pour lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux
certes nous avons en courageusement
ajoutée à notre liste de botswana qui
rejoint dans notre mise à l'index les
sept états encore englobé par notre
vision des paradis fiscaux dont les 1500
habitants de niiu et ne sont pas les
moindres
à l'évidence un changement de braquet
s'impose à moins qu'on ne se
satisfassent du triomphe de l'âge de
l'off shore qui voit singapour
accueillir davantage de dépôts bancaires
que le brésil et le canada réunis les
îles caïmans gérer davantage de
ressources que l'allemagne et les îles
vierges britanniques comptait seize
entreprises par habitant dont au
demeurant une assez grande partie doit
se trouver au chômage
or qui peut se satisfaire de que
l'offshore abri des actifs des ménages
évalué à environ
onze mille milliards de dollars pour des
pertes fiscales considérables pour les
pays de provenance et aux utilisations
incontrôlable et vraisemblablement pour
partie criminelle voire terroristes il
nous faut donc remédier aux faiblesses
de la coordination internationale de la
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
outre sur les efforts de votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre on
devrait pouvoir compter en ce domaine
sur l'europe mais malheureusement la
consistance de l'action européenne est
là comme ailleurs dans le champ fiscal
beaucoup trop mince pour tout dire
l'europe a été trop absente d'une action
qui a pris racine dans le g20 c'est à
dire dans une enceinte de coordination
molle et ambiguë si je me réfère aux
positions de nos partenaires chinois qui
ne semble guère favorable à cette
politique et à celle des états unis qui
obéissent à des principes de géométrie
variable dont une année dont une analyse
géopolitique pourrait révéler les
intentions mais si l'europe ne fait
presque rien dans le monde
c'est sans doute qu'elle commence par ne
presque rien faire chez elle on sait que
la zone euro n'est pas une zone
monétaire optimale
on doit reconnaître que l'union
européenne c'est un euphémisme n'est pas
davantage une zone fiscale optimale rien
ou presque n'est prévu pour réguler les
chocs fiscaux que les états s'infligent
les uns aux autres et ce qui est encore
plus préoccupant
on laisse subsister des comportements
fiscaux hautement dommageable
le code de conduite qui avait été créé
pour lutter contre la concurrence
fiscale dommageable ne suffit plus c'est
évident de toute façon il ne couvrait
pas la fiscalité des particuliers
la directive épargne est bloqué par
quelques-uns de nos partenaires au nom
de l'existence de paradis fiscaux
extérieurs à l'union européenne
de son côté la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
approfondie sans cesse une jurisprudence
qui juge la moindre mesure de régulation
à l'aune des principes sacrés des
traités sans se préoccuper le moins du
monde des ruptures d' équilibre que
cette jurisprudence occasionne dans les
contrats sociaux propres à chaque pays
elle favorise les comportements de
passager clandestin qui mine ses
équilibres vous le savez bien monsieur
ministre puisque l'audit des finances
publiques réalisées par la cour des
comptes vous a alerté sur l'ampleur des
risques financiers résultant de certains
contentieux qui par plusieurs aspects
porte directement sur ces questions
j'ajoute que la commission denquête a pu
identifier un risque non négligeable en
lien avec la fiscalité des transferts de
sièges sociaux d'entreprises
je n'évoque pas ici la juriste près
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme dont certains prolongement
pourrait se révéler totalement
destructeur pour toute forme de vie
collective manifestement ces
constructions prétorienne n'ont que
faire des conclusions du gafi dont les
rapports alerte sur les graves
insuffisances des cadres législatifs et
réglementaires existants dans nombre de
pays européens où très étroitement lié à
l'union européenne pour maîtriser les
risques de blanchiment notamment de
fraude fiscale
tout cela laisse union européenne sans
véritable réaction
notre pays n'est pas exempt de reproche
puisque en son temps nous avons
semble-t-il préféré inscrire à l'ordre
du jour du conseil ecofin la baisse de
la tva sur la restauration plutôt que le
projet axis d'assiette consolidé
d'imposition des sociétés qui pourtant
devrait être un moyen de lutter contre
les effets de l'évasion fiscale
favorable à la france
on va également indiqué que nous avions
refusé de participer à un groupe de
travail réuni pour examiner les
problèmes posés par le liechtenstein
après la découverte de la liste de la
banque lgt présidée par le prince de ce
pays au moins la france sans le teil
défendre une position de principe sur
les affaires rubik
mais elle paraît de plus en plus isolé
ses partenaires créant une brèche dans
la seule position commune de l'europe à
savoir sa pétition de principe de
privilégier l'échangé d'informations
avec les tiers
on pourrait se dire que la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale en europe pourrait
passer par des coordinations renforcée
puisque les principaux problèmes sont le
fait soit de petits pays qui ont un
intérêt majeur à pratiquer les
politiques fiscales non coopérative soit
deux pays a intérêt financier
considérable et à tradition européenne
fluctuante mais il faut bien reconnaître
que les tentations de pays comme
l'allemagne ou l'italie de céder sur les
principes sont peu engageante mais le
sursaut est possible et nous sommes
confrontés à des choix historiques
je n'ai pas en tête seulement la sphère
publique mais aussi plus largement ce
qui se joue au coeur même de l'europe
dans les pays fondateurs qui laisse
libre champ aux pratiques sur lesquelles
se fondent l'évasion fiscale
internationale
je crois qu'il est grand temps de
progresser vers une intégration de la
politique de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale en europe qui ne s'interdisent
pas de reconnaître que l'évasion fiscale
existe au coeur même de l'europe
c'est dans cet esprit que doivent être
appréciés les différentes propositions
qui ont trait à la dimension européenne
de notre sujet et sur lesquels je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez nous
donner le sentiment de
mais nous attendons que la diplomatie
économique que vous avez à raison
souhaité renforcer permet de discipliner
les pratiques fiscales en europe de
sorte que cesse la guerre fiscale que se
livrent les états au détriment les uns
des autres mais aussi des contribuables
qui ne contourne pas leurs dettes
fiscales et qui globalement sont les
moins favorisés ne saurions trop vous
inviter à faire tout pour que les
révisions des directives dont les trous
favorisent l'évasion fiscale en europe
la directive épargne celle sur
l'information des sociétés celles sur
des intérêts et des redevances celle sur
les mères et filiales intervienne au
plus vite
nous attendons une europe plus cohérente
et plus forte passe aux paradis fiscaux
à tous les paradis fiscaux c'est-à-dire
également à ce qu'elle nourrit en son
sein ou à sa très proche périphérie
insistons encore pour que dans les
débats que nous aurons sur la
supervision bancaire en europe
la lutte contre le blanchiment de la
fraude fiscale soit au coeur des normes
communes du régulateur sommes convaincus
par ailleurs une haute priorité devrait
être accordée à l'instauration d'une
assiette consolidé d'imposition des
sociétés
je voudrais évoquer d'un mot les
problèmes posés par les transferts de
résidence des personnes voire par leur
changement de nationalité
la commission denquête a souhaité que
cette question soit rapidement résolu je
vous invite en particulier à remédier à
l'anomalie que représente la péremption
de la valeur fiscale du capital humain
constitué à partir des investissements
publics
quand des individus qui ont largement
bénéficié les transferts publics
s'exempte par leur changement de
résidence dans la quitter les
contreparties fiscale dans un tout autre
domaine la résiliation de la convention
fiscale entre la france et un danemark
ne se résignant pas avoir les revenus
différés constitue au danemark taxi en
france illustrent cette problématique en
ce qui concerne la dimension domestiques
de la politique de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
je voudrais mettre en évidence un
certain nombre le problème auquel l
assemblée à la commission denquête se
trouvait se trouver confrontés je crois
possible de résumer ces différents
problèmes en évoquant le monopole
contestée de l'administration fiscale ou
si vous voulez les limites d'une action
publique qui repose sur l'ambition de
l'administration fiscale d'être au
centre ou en surplomb de tout ce modèle
subi un lourd et un sourd effritement et
s'y agripper à tout prix serait sans
doute une erreur
reconnaissons d'abord que la citadelle
bercy entre guillemets comme on la nomme
parfois a fait des progrès pour dépasser
le principe traditionnel des baronnies
qui l'animait la direction générale des
finances publiques
a finalement vu le jour et en son sein a
été créé un service du contrôle fiscal
ces évolutions n'empêche pas le maintien
d'une superposition de structures
internes à la dg fixes qui sont
spécialisés selon des découpages
fonctionnel qui ne vont pas de soi tout
particulièrement pour les affaires à
forts enjeux fiscaux les problèmes de
coordination régulièrement évoqué par la
cour des comptes s'aggrave sans doute du
fait du maintien hors d g fit deux
structures qui restent en marge pour des
raisons qu'on peut comprendre mais avec
des effets peu favorable pour le
contrôle fiscal j'ai en tête les douanes
mais aussi la direction générale du
trésor l'insee la dgcis qui sont des
directions stratégiques
apparemment peu moins suffisamment
impliqué alors que s'y trouvent des
ressources d'intelligence économique
évidente est particulièrement nécessaire
à une action qui réclament des efforts
soutenus l'observation et l'analyse
je relève également la pause le
positionnement peu lisible de la
délégation interministérielle à
l'intelligence économique
la diversité des intervenants s'accentue
quand on élargit le point de vue en
dehors du ministère des finances
au demeurant la commission denquête a
relevé que ces problèmes de coordination
donné lieu à la création de structures
de coordination qui foisonnent mais
semble parfois hors d'état de coordonner
quoi que ce soit nous l'avons senti avec
le club mais nous pourrions également
cité la délégation nationale à la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux
tout en saluant l' intime connaissance
sur son sujet de son sujet par monsieur
d'aubert qui la préside en même temps
que le forum chargé de la revue par les
pairs ou encore sur les fonctions de la
délégation nationale à la lutte contre
la fraude
outre les questions pratiques que pose
cette organisation à tous les niveaux de
sa conduite il faut bien reconnaître
qu'elle ne favorise pas la lisibilité et
la visibilité d'une action publique qui
devait être plus transparente et plus
largement exposée à l'appréciation de
nos concitoyens c'est pour cet ensemble
de raisons que la commission denquête a
préconisé la création d'un haut
commissariat à la protection des
intérêts financiers publics qui ne
s'ajouteraient pas aux structures
existantes mais les sublimerait en
quelque sorte la place de l'autorité
judiciaire et son rôle dans la politique
de lutte contre l'évasion fiscale sont
un sujet à part entière nous avons connu
une phase judiciarisation de l'action de
l'administration fiscale avec la
création d'officiers fiscaux judiciaires
le renforcement des liens avec la police
judiciaire à la création du flagrant
fiscale de son côté l'autorité
judiciaire pénètre dans la gestion des
fraudes fiscales en s'efforçant de
réunir les moyens de traiter ces
dossiers
ce qui suppose l'accès à des
informations que le mauvais
fonctionnement de la coopération
judiciaire dans le champ fiscal ne
permet pas souvent des compétences
techniques difficiles à réunir
qui demandent des affaires dans la
complexité n'est pas à démontrer malgré
la contrainte des effectifs très forte
qu'elle subit elle le fait aussi en
élargissant le champ de son intervention
de ce dernier point de vue elle procède
- par l'exercice de ses compétences
spécifiques de répression de la fraude
fiscale qui sont soumis à des limites
notamment du fait de la règle qui confie
un monopole de l'action publique au
ministère du budget que par d'autres
voies plus détournée comme celles
offertes par la répression des
infractions connexes à la fraude
notamment celles prévues au code
monétaire et financier
de façon générale la commission denquête
a pu constater un certain manque de
vigueur de la répression pénale de la
fraude fiscale qui par ailleurs se
trouve soumise à un double verrou celui
du ministre du budget et celui des
procureurs
quant à la politique pénale de
répression de l'évasion fiscale
proprement dites elles restent à définir
car si l'évasion fiscale est parfois
sanctionnée administrativement elle
paraît systématiquement échapper aux
sanctions pénales
la commission a examiné le rôle de la
commission des infractions fiscales et
le monopole de saisine a attribué au
ministre du budget sans remettre en
cause l'esprit du dispositif
elle a souhaité qu'un certain nombre de
clarifications puisse intervenir
notamment sur le contrôle de
l'appréciation de l'opportunité des
poursuites
tant au niveau ministériel qu'à celui
des parquets est la paille a par
ailleurs relevé les difficultés posées
par les appréciations divergentes porté
sur la question la loyauté l'épreuve et
par la mise en oeuvre de l'article 40 du
code de procédure pénale est suggéré
quelques solutions
il existe une tendance récente notables
qui voit se diversifier les modalités de
maîtrise de la fraude et de l'évasion
fiscale j'ai plus haut évoqué le gafi
qui correspond un processus visant à
contrôler les fraudes au plus près du
terrain
je pense que cette diversification de la
sen public est louable parce qu'elle
manifeste la préoccupation de compenser
les effets d'une dérégulation accessible
qui a fait perdre au gouvernement la
plupart de leurs instruments de contrôle
et de maîtrise de la vie financière
je voudrais également évoqué avant de
terminer la conception un peu irénique
de l'action de contrôle administration
des finances qui peuvent la conduire à
privilégier une position de surplomb
régalien et à sous-estimer
difficultés auxquelles se trouve
confronté la commission a conclu à la
nécessité de développer les moyens du
contrôle et nous souhaitons que les
réductions d'emplois de la dg fip
n'ampute pas ses moyens
par ailleurs la diversification des
qualifications et leur mise à niveau
doivent être des efforts constants faut
conclure bien il en vient à la
conclusion mme hélène je rappelle tout
simplement que notre homologue américain
sur ce sujet dispose en son sein d'un
sous comité permanent qui fait référence
par ses travaux dans le monde entier je
crois qu'on pourrait s'inspirer de ce
sujet je crois également que la
constitution en france autour de ces
questions d'un réseau d'organisations
non gouvernementales très dévoué et
active en lien avec des organisations
analogues dans les pays partenaires de
la france peut être un vrai stimulant
pour un engagement pérenne de notre
haute assemblée s'agissant d'un sujet
aussi essentiel de notre pacte
républicain
deux secondes encore pour m'associer à
l'hommage rendu par philippe dominati
aux administrateurs disent nahd qui ont
eu une implication très forte dans le
travail et qui ont permis que cette
commission fonctionne dans d'excellentes
conditions
merci de votre attention merci monsieur
le rapporteur de la commission
dans la suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes
j'appelle jacques chiron
madame la présidente
madame le ministre sir collègues j'ai eu
l'honneur de participer pendant six mois
aux travaux qui ont permis de rendre
public le 24 juillet dernier un rapport
adopté à l'unanimité des membres de la
commission denquête a été précisé sur
l'évasion fiscale ce rapport comporte
soit soixante et une proposition et de
nombreux outils qui vont permettre
j'espère au gouvernement de travailler
avec un état des lieux précis des
schémas d'eva d'évasion et
d'optimisation l'unanimité du vote de la
commission traduit un consensus sur les
grands constats mais aussi sur les
pistes à suivre afin de lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale internationale
elle traduit aussi l'état d'esprit qui a
guidé nos travaux et je tiens à
remercier le président philippe dominati
le rapporteur éric bocquet et comme
comme vous l'avez déjà fait l'ensemble
des administrateurs et services du sénat
pour ce travail remarquable concernant
nos propositions
je veux en retenir d'abord une qui me
semblent particulièrement indispensable
et vous l'avez déjà évoqué le sujet de
l'heure à porter la création d'un haut
commissariat la protection des intérêts
financiers publics
le haut-commissariat assurerait à la
fois des fonctions de pilotage de
coordination et d expertise dans notre
politique de lutte contre l'évasion
chargé de formuler des propositions en
matière législative et réglementaire
ils pourraient être placés sur
l'autorité directe du premier ministre
pour coordonner les différents services
en charge de la fraude et l'évasion qui
relèvent de plusieurs ministères il nous
permettrait de disposer enfin d'une
expertise de haut niveau nécessaire pour
faire face à la complexité des procédés
utilisés par les cas particuliers les
entreprises qui ont de plus en plus
recours à des conseils de spécialistes
pour optimiser leurs revenus et impôts
je souhaiterais aussi pour ma part
insisté sur un point particulier car
comme vous l'avez compris et constater
en écoutant leurs le rapporteur le sujet
est vaste
j'insisterai partie
particulièrement sur la liste et
coordination des pays à l'échelle
européenne
en effet les auditions et des placements
réalisés par la commission denquête
montcler différentiel important d'un
pays à l'autre dans l'union européenne
en matière de politique fiscale 7
existantes de multiples régimes fiscaux
encourage les entreprises et
particuliers a entre guillemets
optimiser leurs revenus et impôts créer
ainsi une situation due concurrence et
parfois de fraude qui porte à plus de
1000 milliards
le manque à gagner annuel sur l'ensemble
des pays de l'union européenne soit cinq
fois le budget total de l'union
européenne la souveraineté fiscale
pousse les dirigeants nationaux à
construire une stratégie individualisé
qui conduit maj ôta majoritairement à
des accords bilatéraux entre états alors
même qu'un accord à l'échelon de l'union
européenne contribuerait à garantir à
terme une égalité de traitement pour
tous les pays
les progrès à accomplir sur la voie la
concurrence fiscale loyal reste immense
cependant force est de constater que la
situation actuelle permet difficilement
pour le moment la mise en place d'un
dispositif efficace à l'échelle de
l'union européenne même si le plan
d'action de la commission européenne
dont nous avons rencontré certains
représentants à bruxelles notamment le
commissaire michel barnier
ce plan qui a été présenté fin juin pose
des bases intéressantes travail qui
pourrait néanmoins se heurter à
l'obligation d'une amie ni d'unanimité
en matière de taxation fiscale
dans ce contexte il pourrait devenir
pertinent que ceux d'été d'une stratégie
volontariste de coopération fiscale
au moins entre les états de la zone euro
une zone dans laquelle les états ont
déjà accepté une démarche commune
intégrée au tour de l'union heureux à
monétaire l'equilibre des recettes de
recettes de chacun des 17 pays de cette
zone euro conditionne en partie la
stabilité de notre monnaie commune
ce travail de lissage d'harmonisation
doit s'accompagner d'une politique
commune à l'égard des pays tiers
kiss ou qu'ils soient ou non en zone
euro elle permettrait peut-être
collectivement d'être plus fort pour
obtenir l'échangé automatique
d'informations adopter les mesures
coordonnées à l'encontre des
juridictions qui refusent d'appliquer
les principes de bonne gouvernance comme
peut le faire aujourd'hui les états unis
par la force et le poids de son économie
c'est une première étape qui peut
permettre dans un cadre plus favorable
de se donner des règles collectives et
d'inciter des pays tiers à rejoindre en
cours
la démarche dans son rapport 2011
l'organisation transparency
international ti précise que les
difficultés économiques que traverse la
zone euro
je cite sont en partie liés à la
capacité des pouvoirs publics à lutter
contre la corruption et l'évasion
fiscale qui compte parmi les causes en
principal nous en partie de la crise
pour preuve les pays les plus touchés
par la crise de la dette font partie des
états de l'union européenne ayant obtenu
des notes les plus basses dans cette
enquête la grèce et en avant-dernière
place sur les trente pays de la région
union européenne et europe de l'ouest
à ce titre le directeur de la brigade
grecs des contrôles fiscaux à lui-même
reconnu que l'évasion fiscale en grèce
atteint 12 à 15 % du pib soit 40 acres
45 milliard d'euros par an et que s'il
pouvait en récupérer la moitié le
progrès le problème de la grèce serait
en partie résolu l'italie est en 27 et
de place sur la zone euro et on sait et
on a pu voir ces dernières mois le
président du du concept se battre contre
cet état de fait dans ces deux états le
montant des pertes de recettes et de la
même ampleur que l'on entend du déficit
annuel
on le constate cher coffre collègues le
système devient un cercle vicieux
l'apathie des pouvoirs publics à lutter
contre la fraude fiscale génère un
sentiment de défaillance très fort dans
ces pays ces capitaux n'irrigue plus
l'économie nationale déjà en grande
difficulté
sans être la seule explication de la
crise l'évasion et la fraude fiscales
sont aujourd'hui un élément de sa
pérennisation
je tiens également à préciser
et que les opinions publiques
européennes évoluent parfois plus vite
que les dirigeants sur la question c'est
le cas de la suisse dont chacun connaît
les particuliers les particularités sur
le plan fiscal
quatre cantons ont déjà approuvé la
votation citoyenne par par par votation
citoyenne l'abolition du régime fiscal
qui met en place un système d'imposition
très avantageux pour les riches
expatriés et même si certains s'y
refusent encore les chiffres de ces
référendums témoigne d'une avancée la
pression populaire peut permettre
d'accélérer le processus et oblige pour
ceux qui par exemple en suisse pour ceux
qui sont encore réticents à augmenter
des barèmes d'imposition
c'est aujourd'hui la responsabilité des
dirigeants des états européens et
particulièrement de la zone euro
d'expliquer à tous les citoyens que
parallèlement à la crise économique et
sociale que nous traversons il existe
une véritable crise impose de
l'imposition que nous devons traiter en
priorité car c'est aux citoyens qu'on
impose ensuite l'austérité pour
compenser les manques à gagner qu'elle
génère pour l'état le rapport de la
commission denquête propose également
plusieurs pistes pour renforcer la
transparence et la coordination à
l'échelle européenne
sans être exhaustif je veux citer la
création d'un registre pays européens
des trusts la mise en place d'un fichier
européen des comptes bancaires
la création d'une obligation de
transparence comptable pays par pays
pour les multinationales
l'élargissement de rufisque à d'autres
impôts que la tva pour structurer la
coopération entre les administrations
fiscales
l'attribution d'un numéro
d'identification fiscal commun aux
contribuables européens la création à
terme d'une brigade européenne de
contrôler la mise en place d'une
coopération renforcée pour créer une
assiette commune obligatoire pour
l'impôt sur les sociétés toutes ces
propositions sont maintenant la
disposition du gouvernement et peuvent
être proposées dans le cadre de la zone
euro je me réjouis d'ailleurs de voir
depuis plusieurs semaines nos ministres
qui prennent la mesurer l'importance de
cette question
les premières déclarations au sujet de
l'évasion fiscale vont dans le sens
préconisé par le rapport de la
commission denquête pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances a
déjà manifesté le souhait de renégocier
les conventions fiscales avec la suisse
le luxembourg l'autriche et la belgique
laurent fabius maëlys des affaires
étrangères a rencontré dernièrement son
de google de suisse pourrait changer
avec sur les relations fiscales entre
les deux pays notamment sur le sujet de
la convention de double imposition
jérôme cahuzac milices du budget annoncé
le week-end dernier que le gouvernement
prévoyait avant la fin de l'année un
plan de lutte anti-fraude avec des
moyens renforcés pour l'administration
dans ses pouvoirs d'investigation
enquêtes et surtout de recouvrement sa
mise en oeuvre en en 2013 pourrait
permettre de détecter quatre milliards
de fraude fiscale
enfin dans un discours de politique
générale le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault avait déjà mis en avant la
notion de patriotisme fiscale mais avec
ces avec toutes les bonnes volontés que
nous devons continuer d'avancer sur ce
dossier majeur dans le contexte que
chacun connaît il est indispensable de
renforcer enfin l'équilibré l'efficacité
de notre système de prélèvements
obligatoires
les moyens mobilisés pour lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale et la fraude fiscales
doivent être à la hauteur des agents td
des attentes et des enjeux à la hauteur
de notre ambition de justice alors que
nous nous nous demandons un effort
important ou français pour redresser
notre situation budgétaire
on ne peut accepter que certains
notamment ceux qui ont le plus de moyens
puissent aussi facilement s'en
affranchir merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
nathalie goulet la présidente même le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur mais
sert collègues trop eux c'est trop trop
de fraudes trop d'évasion fiscale trop
de réglementations et partant trop de
failles bien exploité par trop de fins
limiers de l'évasion trop bien formés
trop de carences dans les moyens en
hommes et en formation trop peu de
moyens pour les parquets trop peu de
coopération internationale trop de
carences dans les échanges
d'informations trop d'organismes trop
étanche aux missions trop c'est quand
c'est trop de carences dans une volonté
politique nationale et internationale
trop c'est trop et ce rapport trop
volumineux de 2000 pages en est le
reflet c'est assez rare que les mots me
manquent mais je dois dire que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à choisir les actes les
axes de mon intervention dans les
travaux de notre commission était riche
et divers comment faire le tri parmi
soixante et une proposition toutes plus
intéressantes les unes que les autres
de la simple réorganisation technique
aux actes de formation en passant par
des mesures législatives ou
réglementaires nationales ou
internationales sans doute privilégié
même le ministre celle qui ne coûte rien
un regret monsieur cambadélis ne soit
pas que monsieur cambadélis ne soit pas
dans nos tribunes
je plaisante que vous connaissez les
femmes toujours un peu rancunière malin
le ministre donc choisi l'illustration
nourrissant un doute sur la capacité des
uns et des autres
à lire les deux mille pages de ce
rapport dans le domaine de la fraude
nous sommes dans la guerre de l'eau bue
et du blindage quand le blindage et le
droit fiscal
il ressemble déjà à une passoire qui
fait les beaux jours des fiscalistes
averti et des fraudeurs j'ai choisi de
m'intéresser à l'administration des
douanes pour laquelle j'ai une tendresse
particulière
cette administration est exemplaire et
semble-t-il un peu désarmée traité à la
marge comme dit philip cox secrétaire
général du syndicat solidaires des
douanes dans une audition du 3 avril
dernier un petit rappel en 2010 91
millions d'euros au titre des sommes non
déclarées à l'exportation tout de même
été enregistré c'est moins qu'en 2009 où
on avait récupéré 188 millions d'euros
illustration extraits du rapport page
j'ai préféré lire le rapport ça vaut
mieux que n'importe quel autre
explication sur interrogations nous
avons yeux le cas assez récemment d'une
personne qui circule sur le périphérique
avec huit cent mille euros cachés dans
la roue de secours de son véhicule les
gens sont distraits je ne suis pas
nécessairement face à un manquement de
l'obligation déclarative dit le
secrétaire général
rien ne me prouve que cette personne et
vous le franchir la frontière certes
elles étaient seulement sur le
périphérique
donc là des premiers enjeux pour les
douaniers même s'ils ont trouvé l'argent
dans la roue de secours comme un endroit
assez classique pour placer une somme de
cette importance en soit portée de
l'argent à le faire circuler à
l'intérieur du territoire n'est pas une
infraction
oui mais derrière il faut juridiquement
appuyer la distraction sur quelque chose
de plus solide
ce qu'on essaye de faire dans ce cas là
c'était éventuellement vie à l'article
40 de renvoyer une enquête pour une
saisie soit de la douane judiciaire soit
d'un autre service d'ailleurs qui peut
être un service de l'état afin d'essayer
d'arriver à démontrer que cet argent
provient effectivement d'une opération
de blanchiment et d'une infraction
sous-jacent en l'espèce
mes chers collègues faute de preuves
l'argent a été rendu le système on
applique au quotidien pour la lutte
contre la fraude a été largement
largement désarmé notamment sur la
frontière avec le luxembourg
et là c'est l'audition de monsieur bob
crow secrétaire du secret du
syndicat solidaires douanes toujours le
3 avril que je voudrais vous mentionnez
sur le terrain originaire de l'est j'ai
souvent le souvenir de douane
extrêmement efficace dit-il du côté de
thionville qui était la terreur du
luxembourg je me demande si les banques
luxembourgeoises ont sablé le champagne
que nous avons changé notre dispositif
ces unités ne rentrait jamais
bredouilles sans vous donner trop
d'astuces pour fraude et vous prenez le
train direct pour luxembourg allait
d'abord ahmed fil des heures
c'est une chose toute bête et qui marche
très bien donc aujourd'hui nous a donné
un autre exemple je vais vous donner
l'exemple dit il d'une situation certes
caricatural mais devant laquelle nous
sommes trouvés il ya quinze jours elle
est d'ailleurs assez gênante
vous allez voir on comprend pourquoi
elle est assez gênante nous avons
intercepté des personnes se déplaçant
entre les pays bas la france et
l'espagne transportant chose tout à fait
interdit un montant excessif d'espèces
imprégné de cocaïne trois cent mille
euros
on applique donc l'amendé forfaitaire d'
abaisser dans le rapport monsieur de
raincourt c'est pas énorme mais enfin on
pourrait on pourrait s'en contenter mais
c'est bien vous disiez que ce soit pas
énorme je dire ça c'est ça éclaire nos
débats donc on applique une amende de 25
% et on renvoie le reste de l'argent par
virement l'exemple est extrême c'est une
hérésie
là on atteint vraiment les limites du
système donc vous voyez on est passé de
la théorie à la pratique sur deux cas
absolument symptomatique de ce qu'on a
entendu monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur pendant la totalité de nos
audiences donc la liste des mesures que
nous proposons est évidemment exhaustive
mais l'exemple
les deux exemples que je viens de vous
citer sont extrêmement frappant et et
vous prendre font prendre conscience de
l'importance qu'il y a les uns et les
autres à lire cet excellent rapport je
voudrais aussi évoqué brièvement la
fraude au remboursement de la tva
on a signalé des cas de remboursement de
tva au profit de personnes qui
manifestement jongle sur les passeports
sans que quiconque ne puisse vérifier la
réalité de leur domiciliation ça je
pense qu'il serait extrêmement
importante donner des moyens aux doigts
c'est aux douaniers de
si pour pouvoir vérifier ces choses on
parle de remboursement de tva de 750000
euros ou de plusieurs fois deux cent
mille euros
et là vous avez la grande solitude des
douaniers de roissy qui se rendent
compte qu'il y à une présomption de
fraude et qui n'ont aucun moyen de
vérifier la domiciliation de gens qui
circulent avec plusieurs passeports
bon j'ai vu j'ai essayé d'éviter un
inventaire à la prévert mais je voudrais
même le ministre insiste et comme l'ont
fait des orateurs avant moi en attendant
le grand soir d'une grande loi contre
l'évasion fiscale
mettre en place une cellule de notre de
suivi de notre travail je pense que
c'est extrêmement important
même si cette cellule n'a pas une forme
institutionnelle même si ce n'est pas
une commission parce que vous savez que
les uns et les autres nous sommes tous
très occupés parfois ne pourront pas
assister aux réunions mais je pense
qu'il faut une cellule informel de suivi
des propositions qui sont faites par
notre commission
je souhaiterais également plus
sérieusement vous à nous interroger sur
la question de l'utilité de la
commission des infractions fiscales
nous avons entendu son président et je
persiste à penser que cette commission
n'est pas forcément utile ni efficace
dans sa forme actuelle
quant au type hôtel son pouvoir quasi
discrétionnaire n'être absolument pas
compatible avec la transparence dont
doit faire preuve la justice fiscale à
l'égard de nos concitoyens
que dire enfin et pour conclure de 4500
euros en espèces
nonchalamment parier par des joueurs de
hand ball de d'une grande chaîne de
télévision qui donne cent mille francs
cent mille euros en espèces à l'issue
d'un jeu télévisé ou du code des douanes
madame le ministre qui ne comporte plus
aucun article concernant l'or aucun
article que vous pouvez vous promener
mal le ministre avec plusieurs lingots
dans vos valises sans que le code des
douanes ne puisse à aucun moment vous
réprimer sujet trop grave d'entre aux
coups
trop de questions encore sans réponse et
vous n'aurez pas trop madame le ministre
de cinq ans pour y répondre
merci merci chers collègues
c'est bien connu que nous avons tous
besoin de 800000 euros dans le trou de
secours pour régler le péage c'est bien
connu bien la parole est à yvon collin
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues et j'ai l'honneur en
qualité de vice-président de participer
à la commission d' enquête sur l'évasion
des capitaux et des actifs hors de
france mais aussi de ses incidences
fiscales
régis commission présidée avec talent
par philippe dominati et dont les
travaux ont été excellemment rapportés
par notre collègue éric bocquet
l'évasion des capitaux est un sujet
sensible de surcroît dans un contexte de
crise
un moment où l'objectif de réduction des
déficits publics appelle un effort de la
part de tous particuliers et entreprises
le comportement de quelques-uns
régulièrement pointé du doigt parfois
avec fracas la presse a révélé des
failles du système fiscal
il fallait donc un travail profond tel
que celui effectué pendant ces mois par
la commission d' enquête pour retracer
avec précision l'identité de l'évasion
fiscale internationale en mesurer les
enjeux et proposer quelques
recommandations pour tenter d'y mettre
un terme
loeffler d'évasion fiscale et d'une
telle ampleur qu'il nous faut rester
vigilants et surtout très mobilisés vous
connaissez les chiffres la fraude
représenterait 2 à 5% du pib de l'union
européenne
pour la france ce serait 40 milliards
d'euros qui s'évapore et chaque année en
montant à m bien entendu en parallèle
avec les 20 milliards d'euros madame la
ministre
d'impôts supplémentaires qui seront
demandés dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2013 ce sont les
contribuables qui n'ont aucune
échappatoire fiscale qui contribueront
le plus au redressement de la france
tandis que d'autres continueront à se
soustraire à l'un des devoirs les plus
élémentaires de la citoyenneté
parce que ce manque de cohésion fiscal
est porteur de forts déséquilibres
économiques nous devons agir agir
rapidement d'autant plus vite que la
mondiale minent mondialisation va
compliquer la tâche
la complexité déjà ancienne du système
fiscal hexagonal s'inscrit désormais
dans un monde de flux matériel et
immatériel
pour ma part sur ce vaste sujet je
souhaite évoquer le problème de la
concurrence fiscale au sein de l'europe
tant que certains de nos propres voisins
continueront à offrir des conditions
fiscales plus attractive allant jusqu à
le proclamer au plus haut niveau
cette harmonisation fiscale européenne a
minima constituera un obstacle pour
parler d'une seule voix au niveau
international
et même si c'est vrai le g20 s'est
préoccupé le plus fermement de cette
question en 2008
en dressant avec le cd la fameuse liste
des états et territoires non coopératifs
mais vous connaissez tous mes chers
collègues les limites des conventions
d'échangé d'informations fiscales
je pense donc qu'il faudrait dépasser le
stade de l'information pour mettre en
oeuvre des dispositifs plus contraignant
à l'échelle internationale et comme je
les dis une véritable harmonisation
fiscale pour l'europe
on pourrait par exemple décliné ce qui a
été entrepris pour la tva
les textes ont été adoptés sur le
fondement de l'article 113 du traité sur
le fonctionnement de l'union européenne
afin d'harmoniser la fiscalité indirecte
cette initiative a conduit l'office
européen anti fraude olaf a développé
une stratégie de lutte contre la tvr
permettant dès 2008 d'accélérer la
collecte et l'échangé d'informations sur
les transactions intra communautaires la
fraude à la tva sur les importations est
également correctement traitée au niveau
européen est en fait le paquet tva
imposera l'horizon 2015 les services de
communications électroniques et les
services fournis par voie électronique
dans l'état membre où est établi le
consommateur et si ce même effort que
nous devrions faire s'agissant de la
fiscalité directe
notre pays ne pourra pas supporter
encore longtemps
la fidh fiscal en particulier sur ses
bases des plus mobile comme vous le
savez madame la ministre la france est
particulièrement exposé compte tenu de
son niveau
la taxation du capital et les revenus
des sociétés notre pays en tout cas le
mérite pour le soulier de faire des
efforts d'harmonisation même quand ceux
ci se révèlent unilatéraux je pense en
particulier à l'article
15 du projet de loi de finances pour
2013 qui aménage la déductibilité des
charges financières comme le cin comme
vous avez eu l'occasion de le souligner
madame la ministre ce régime était trop
permissifs en comparaison de celui des
autres états membres de l'union
européenne
vous avez donc raison d'instaurer un
plafonnement ce premier pas vers une
normalisation du financement des
entreprises est une bonne chose mais si
le son côté par exemple la belgique
déduit à la fois les intérêts d'emprunt
et les intérêts notionnels
on se trouve toujours dans un contexte
de concurrence fiscale
enfin qu'à l'allemagne mais aussi la
grande-bretagne s'il de leur côté des
accords dits rubik avec la suisse je ne
suis pas certain que ce soit un bon
signal pour l'europe
ces deux états membres jouant leur
propre partition ont fait le choix qui
ne s'inscrit pas vraiment dans la
démarche européenne en faveur de la
transparence et d'échangé d'informations
et j'insiste donc sur le volet de
l'harmonisation fiscale en europe et sur
celui de la coordination de la politique
de lutte contre l'évasion fiscale deux
axes rendu plus que nécessaire par les
difficultés budgétaires de la plupart
des étapes maman parmi toutes les
dimensions et la nombreuse ça a été dit
le rapport abanda le souligne de
l'évasion fiscale je souhaiterais aussi
évoqué le cas des pays en développement
en ma qualité de rapporteur spécial du
budget de l'aide publique au
développement je me désespère du manque
à gagner de nombreux pays victime d'un
véritable hold up
selon un membre de la plate forme
paradis fiscaux et judiciaires des
multinationales pratique l'optimisation
fiscale et des places leur assiette
fiscale
certains pays d'afrique voit ainsi la
ressource pillé sans aucun retour fiscal
les montants de cette évasion estimée à
800 milliards d'euros représente plus de
10 fois l'aide publique au développement
et ces comportements sont une source
d'instabilité majeur que leur apporte
une pays par pays pourrait limiter
il met en tout cas en exergue le
problème général de déconnexion entre la
ressource fiscale et la source et
de la création de valeur il faut
restaurer ce lien si simple
malheureusement brisées par des
mécanismes souvent volontairement
complexe et volontairement opaque à mes
chers collègues la tâche vous l'aurez
compris est immense mais nous pouvoir
heureusement constater qu'il existe une
prise de conscience à différents
échelons des conséquences économiques et
sociales de l'évasion des capitaux
notre commission denquête a émis
soixante et une proposition qui je
l'espère retiendront madame la ministre
toute votre attention je formule en tout
cas le voeu que ce travail soit
poursuivie au sénat ça a été dit
également il ya quelques minutes sous
une forme bien sûr qu'il nous restera à
déterminer mais je sais que notre
premier chantier est de rétablir
l'équité fiscale sur notre propre
territoire il a déjà beaucoup à faire
au delà des mécanismes fiscaux qu'il
convient de toiletter pour éviter l'
optimisation abusive je crois qu'il faut
aussi rappeler tout simplement le sens
de l'impôt à ce qu'ils auraient trop tôt
oublier nos routes nos écoles nos
hôpitaux sont le fruit de la solidarité
fiscale
tous ceux qui s'évade en belgique ou en
suisse n'ont ils jamais profiter de tous
ces services publics
et quand bien même il y aurait-il plus
contribué que les autres le pacte
républicain qui s'est parfois construit
dans le sens mérite en ce sens le
respect et l'attitude irréprochable de
ceux qui ont la chance d'avoir plus je
vous remercie mes chers collègues merci
chers collègues
la parole est à corinne bouchoux
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président mes chers collègues alors
qu'il est tout a été dit sur le sujet
vous êtes là vous avez tous lu les 1200
pages du rapport vous connaissez nos 60
propositions par coeur et il va donc
être difficile de céder à l'originalité
je vais donc essayé d'insister sur deux
ou trois points qui n'ont pas été
mentionnés par mes collègues le premier
point sur lequel je voudrais insister au
risque de paraître iconoclaste c'est que
nous portons une part de responsabilité
nous législateurs dans ce que nous
dénonçons en effet la variabilité des
mesures fiscales d'année en année à
développer l'industrie du conseil et
l'industrie qui favorise la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale
nous devons donc nous intégrer à cette
problèmatique deuxième point sur lequel
je voudrais insister c'est que nous
devons bien sûr balayer tous devant
notre porte et voir qu'au niveau
européen il y à des pays qui veulent
tout à la fois les avantages de l'europe
et de la libre circulation sans reculer
sur le secret bancaire là aussi nous ne
ferons pas l'économie d'une autre
approche avec un certain nombre de nos
voisins même si ce sont nos amis depuis
très longtemps
troisième point sur lequel je voudrais
insister excusez moi c'est une manie
personnel chez moi et en mes dadas
c'est un sujet qui illustre cette
problématique et ricky risque dans les
mois à venir de nous poser quelques
problèmes
c'est la question des trusts il me
semble que la suggestion faite par le
rapport de créer un registre européen
des trusts répondant avec un certain
nombre de critères avec des seuils
d'actifs sous jacents et déclarant
l'objet et le contenu du trust seraient
hautement utile
nous nous permettons au passage madame
la ministre d'attirer mahb le mans votre
attention sur les trusts wildenstein
dont il va être question aux états unis
d'ici un mois et qui pourrait à l'avenir
mettre en situation extrêmement
inconfortable certains de nos musées
même s'ils ont eu une politique
volontariste sur les tableaux mnr en
matière de treuils wildenstein c'est un
dossier délicat qui s'ouvre à nous
dernier point que je voudrais signaler
et c'est un oubli un angle mort de notre
travail et à la veille d'un rendez vous
très important sur l'acte iii de la
décentralisation je voudrais me up athlé
un petit peu c'est un oubli
les collectivités territoriales peuvent
jouer un rôle très important et jouent
parfois un rôle concernant la lutte
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
alors je vais simplement prendre deux
exemples extrêmement basique que l'on
m'a signalé dans certains conseils
régionaux des motions ont été votés afin
de soumettre toutes les activités de la
région avec des bancs ou avec des
partenaires un certain nombre de règles
de transparence et donc ce n'est pas la
panacée mais cela peut marcher cela
montre que celle affaires de l'état
c'est bien sûr mes collègues m'ont dit
la sphère des entreprises qui doivent
être vertueuse mais les collectivités
locales peuvent jouer un rôle positif au
niveau régional et on m'a signalé aussi
le cas tout à fait intéressant à
l'échelle d'agglomération ou
d'intercommunalité qui elles aussi ont à
coeur de travailler avec des bancs ou
avec des entreprises qui ne pratiquent
pas la fraude et l'évasion fiscale mais
qui sont vertueuses avant de de
développer un dernier point je voudrais
dire que l'or alors que notre situation
budgétaire est particulièrement délicate
alors que tout le monde va faire un
certain nombre d'efforts je voudrais
signaler ici un paradoxe qu'il y a dans
ce pays le sujet de la fraude et
d'évasion fiscale et de la lutte contre
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale et sous
documenté au plan académique
universitaire nous avons énormément de
boncourt sur comment frauder le fisc
nous avons énormément d'entreprises de
conseils qui sont excellentes sur
comment faire de l'évasion fiscale et il
me semble extrêmement important en
matière de recherche publique public
d'encourager des recherches
indépendantes sur ce dossier et je
voudrais en même temps signalé quelque
chose que certains d'entre nous de la
commission remarquer nous pourrions ne
faire que cela
c'est à dire qu'il ya une demande dans
la population de pédagogie
d'explicitation de ce qu'est la fraude
de ce qu'est l'évasion fiscale et nous
pourrions être même plus ici et en étant
en causerie conférence tant les
sollicitations sont importants dans
l'opinion publique et je pense
extrêmement important de répondre à
cette attente pas seulement par de la
communication sur le rapport ce que nous
avons tous essayé de faire avec nos
sensibilités cet été mais je pense que
nous avons ici en tant que pouvoir
législatif une responsabilité majeure à
savoir de prendre en compte ce dossier
d'avoir une politique lisible et
d'essayer parmi les soixante et une
proposition que nous avons faite d'en
trouver au moins trois ou quatre qui
pourrait être appliquée
donc la première sans que cela coûte un
centime puisque nous avons un certain
nombre de personnes compétentes
d'autorité très direct très instruite
qui pourrait le faire la mise en place
d'un comité qui à la fois permettrait
annuellement de faire de l'évaluation de
la fraude de voir les travaux
universitaires sur le sujet et de faire
un petit peu un observatoire en temps
réels permettraient de relayer utilement
ce dossier qui est extrêmement important
dernier point et vous savez que dans la
famille écologiste on n'est pas
forcément des adeptes de la répression
pour avoir étudié les jurisprudence en
matière de fraude et d'évasion fiscale
j'invite tous mes collègues à le faire
et bien la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
en france est nettement moins punis et
je le regrette que le vol de scooter est
donc dans un pays où ont puni plus
sévèrement en nombre et plus gravement
les jeunes et je le regrette c'est
inacceptable qui veulent des scooters et
que l'on est tolérant et souple
vis-à-vis de ceux qui fraudent de ceux
qui gruge et qui fonde la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale alors que ça coûte 50
milliards par an eh bien chers amis je
suis désolé ça va nourrir du poujadisme
ça va nourrir de l'antiparlementarisme
et là on n'a pas le droit d'échouer donc
soit on fait quelque chose et on répond
à l'attenté des français soit on va être
dans une situation extrêmement délicate
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est à françois pillés
madame la présidente madame le ministre
ce président sera porter mes chers
collègues
il est évidemment impossible que la
synthèse de ce rapport sur l'évasion
fiscale internationale autorisée
d'ailleurs à ceux qui l'ont lu puissent
être réalisés rapidement à fortiori en
quelques minutes
je peux assurer que sa lecture est
absolument passionnante tant il permet
de comprendre et d'appréhender
aujourd'hui dans sa totalité le
phénomène étudié au terme de cette
enquête où le président philippe
dominati a permet une exploration
profonde du sujet en dirigeant avec une
autorité souriante des auditions des
débats sans concession et où le reporter
éric bocquet sans renier certaines
analyses qui lui sont propres à proposer
des conclusions qui ont recueilli
l'approbation des l'ensemble des membres
de la commission
je retiendrai après avoir volontairement
il ya quelques secondes élaguer mon
texte de tous les exemples qui vous ont
été donnés sur le constat desquels
d'ailleurs nous avons également fait
l'unanimité
je reviendrai ce qui me permettra d'être
concis une constatation est une
recommandation les deux essentielles
prioritaire est forte
la constatation oui je suit le
rapporteur
le consensus s'est formé au sein de la
commission celui de privilégier le
travail de fond mais aussi celui de la
transparence et surtout il existe et je
le cite encore une forme de consensus
pour repousser l'évasion fiscale
internationale
oui madame le ministre il y à bien là un
consensus républicain
la recommandation toutes les situations
toutes les hypothèses hors-la-loi acte
anormal de gestion abus de droit fraude
fiscale doivent alimenter un autre débat
pour ne pas obscurcir celui sur
l'évasion fiscale sur l'optimisation
fiscale qui elle se loge à l'abri des
tracts et des conventions
internationales
de la loi et de la règlementation
qu'elles sont certaines constatations
incontournable aucune donnée
scientifique précisant les dégâts causés
par l'évaluation fiscale
né à troyes de notre disposition même
même si certaines approches de la
quantification du phénomène sont
plausibles la complexité l'abondance des
textes et de la réglementation favorise
des tunnels d'évasion la coopération
administrative entre états est tout de
même quasiment embryonnaires
l'ingénierie fiscale ou sociale est en
permanente adaptation avec une
efficacité infiniment plus immédiates
que les réactions législatives ou
réglementaires qu'elle sur les efforts
de la france pour lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale le rapport souligne
objectivement les efforts indéniables
réalisés par les années passées ou moins
passé unilatéralement par la france dans
la mise à disposition d'outils
juridiques pour l'administration fiscale
et dans la traduction juridique des
engagements internationaux en droit
interne concerne en particulier les
mesures de rétorsion frappant les états
et les territoires non coopératifs
ce rapport si utilement les mesures
techniques prises qui rendent efficace
un effort de sécurisation de l'assiette
de l'impôt parmi l'inventaire exhaustif
que vous pouvez retrouver dans le
rapport je tiens cet égard a cité par
exemple l'allongement du délai de
reprise de l'administration fiscale
la mise en place de nouvelles procédures
de contrôle en matière de tva et de
flagrance la création de la brigade vous
l'avez cité de la brigade nationale de
répression de la délinquance fiscale
la spécialisation d'agents affectés à la
lutte entre les trafics illicites la
signature de conventions internationales
d'échangés d'informations la création de
l' exit tax
mais comment ne pas regretter ne pas
constater avec regret en tout cas les
l'existence proclamer un manchon
porteuse de progrès d'une circulation
libre des personnes des capitaux des
entreprises d'un marché unique qui est
explosée par 27 souveraineté fiscale en
concurrents
de fait le champ de la compétition
économique ressemble au terme de la
compétition sportive
imaginez la coupe européenne de football
ou voire mieux
la coupe du monde où l'on s'accommode
raid équipes bénéficiant de cash plus
étroite
d'autres jouent à 15 mm pour certaines
avec les mains le tout géré par un
arbitre laissant à chaque fédération
nationale le soin de fixer les règles
applicables à son équipe
l'évasion fiscale qui pénalise notre
pays est animé par la recherche d'un
environnement plus favorable au niveau
de la pression des prélèvements elle se
conjugue d'ailleurs souvent avec une
optimisation des charges sociales le
rapport à avec objectivité admis
pardonnez moi cette expression qui ne
veut pas choquer le rapport admis
l'absence de compétitivité de la france
en matière de prélèvements obligatoires
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi une partie de ce
débat consacré à l'évasion fiscale
à suivre le journal de 19h présenté ce
soir par michel grossiord très bonne
soirée à tous